he's Dan Majerle who's joining us the
Continental Tire coaches corner he of
course is the head coach at Grand Canyon
University they're 20 and 10 and they
start the WAC tournament coming up the
former NBA three-time NBA all-star by
the way and Thunder Dan joining us
how are you coach I'm good how are you I
still my my I still lost you a horse
which is the the worst thing that's ever
happened to me and never I can never
live it down well I don't I wasn't even
gonna bring that up I just said you know
you were so that's okay you wouldn't
close yeah it wasn't a game of horse I
know it was 15 three-pointers yeah okay
but you're over it you're over that was
late I know it was 93 I'm not an athlete
that's what hurt even more well but I
will say this the next night Marlee hits
eight threes so that was that tried to
redeem myself that's right you spurred
me on okay now a couple of reasons why I
wanted to have you on explain to people
the home court advantage that Grand
Canyon has because we've read about it
maybe but if you haven't been there to
see it it's one of the great home court
advantage is it feels like in the
country explain the earlier yeah I don't
know if I can it it's one of those
things that's just as you know built you
know when I got here four years ago
there's 4,000 students on campus and now
there's 19,000 we're gonna cap it at
30,000 so you can imagine you know 3,000
3,500 new freshmen every year and our
fan bases has really grown it's called
the havoc and we fill one half size of
the arena across from our bench with
just with students and it's like a party
it's a raid they get in there an hour
before the game and it's just non-stop
and when I tell recruits I said we have
one of the best you know college
atmospheres in all the country they just
kind of roll their eyes yeah we've heard
this before and we actually had a guy
sign we had a guy come here and it was
an exhibition game and I said wait to
see your crowd he said this is an
exhibition game and I said no just wait
and we won by 40 and the place never sat
down and he signed that night he said
this is unbelievable so you know we
talked about you see the videos but when
you're here it's it's as absolutely
electric and it goes on all game
and when did you guys go to Division one
is this the first year Division one it
was it last year well we'd better in
Division one for you know the transition
period this is the first year that were
eligible for the turnin okay okay yep so
this is our first year so we're you know
really excited
we had 181 games in that four year
transition period which is by far the
best record ever for a transitioning
period team this is the third year in a
row we've won over 20 games so we're
excited come Thursday and in Vegas we'll
be in our first WAC tournament and then
if you win that you qualify for the
tournament automatic bid yep automatic
bid so as I said everybody's really
excited about it we can't wait to get it
go alright after what was it on senior
night you had one of your players get
engaged he proposed to his girlfriend
so this yeah kiante Vernon yeah Kiana
he's a senior he's been with me for
three years a great kid he came into my
office a couple days before all nervous
I didn't know what his problem was
and he said I have to I have to get your
blessing and I said what he said I'm
gonna propose to my girlfriend on screw
your night and I said well I said okay
fortunately I've known this girl for a
long time because you know she works at
my restaurant actually she's worked
there for you know quite a number of
years so I've known her for a long time
she's a great girl and Gabe cannot say
my blessing and he did it right there
and senior night it was a big hit but
you could tell that there was something
on his mind when he comes here you're
you have no idea what's on his mind you
think it's basketball related or school
related yeah I didn't know what was
going on with him he was a little
nervous and I was like what's problems
yeah you know I had no idea and it was
like well this is the most nervous I've
been and I said go ahead just bring it
out and he said I'm gonna propose to my
girlfriend I said you know kind of took
a deep brother sure and they said yeah
I've been thinking about for a while and
I know she is a great girl so I gave my
blessing and it was it was a great
moment for both of us did anybody else
know yeah the whole team knew okay he
knew that and I think everybody knew but
his girlfriend you know agent my manager
knew and Hulk you know I don't think the
crowd knew but the whole teammate I all
the teammates knew and his family knew
so it was pretty cool
was there a back-up plan yeah I saw him
trying to put the ring on his finger and
he was shaking
yeah he was it was like he was trying to
catch a path he hadn't had the greatest
hands in the world that's what I was
gonna say he's probably not very good in
pressure situations there now he's like
a 40% free-throw shooter and fumbled the
ball so he executed the plan perfectly I
was proud of him
did you ever get a sniff to be the son
said coach no no that's why I ended up
here you know I was I was an assistant
with Alvin Gentry and all-star break
decided to go a different way and they
passed over three assistants me being
one of them gave it to Lindsey Hunter I
wasn't happy with it obviously that was
a place that you know I'm in the Ring of
Honor I've played there you know all
that stuff and thought I was I was
qualified to get the next step but then
mr. Colangelo called me and said hey
there's a job right down the street from
where you live it's Grand Canyon they
got a bright future they're gonna go
division one and they want you as a
coach can you sit down the President and
I did and it's the best move I've ever
made it's pretty cool did you ever you
know when we looked at your name how you
spell your name we weren't you know
we're going how do you spell Marley's
name and then all of a sudden it's like
Maj er L II did how long did it take for
people in the NBA to know how to
pronounce your name uh it took a while
everybody know I got invited to the
Olympics in 88 and that was one of the
last people invited to the Olympics I
think it was a hundred and three college
athletes no boy and yeah that was one of
the last ones and I swear to you for the
first week
George raveling who is John Thompson's
assistant would do roll call put us in
groups and the first week he called me
majorly I was like there's no way I'm
gonna make this team the guy doesn't
even know my damn name so finally you
know I practiced pretty well when we
start calling Marlee I said okay maybe I
have a shot of nicotine
here's our poll question would you
rather have six NBA championship rings
or five rings and an Oscar
oh six championship break so you take
Jordan 6 over Kobe's five and an Oscar
that he won last night yeah I've never
I'll be obviously I've never watched the
Oscars all right well then you're
probably the wrong guy to ask this
question but yeah you know both both are
pretty good but you fight against both
ranked who's winning
McLovin who's winning is Kobe's five and
an Oscar yeah 65% voted for Kobe did you
play against Kobe I didn't how much yeah
you know he was obviously younger and I
guard him a few and I can't remember how
much I did play against him but I do
remember playing against him when he was
I think was his rookie year what year
did he come in the league let's see when
he made the trade with Vlade Divac 96
Paulie 96 97 OC you and your crime yeah
well I was out of my prime a long time
ago I was still fooling them but I
retired in 2002 so yeah I played against
him for you know quite a bit but back
then I was back in the I was back with
Miami and E so I wouldn't played with
him as much just if I was still with the
Suns okay so yeah I was still playing
against Jordan and those guys but is it
cool to tell your plate like your
players want to know about you when you
played and played against Jordan oh yeah
they asked all the time and you know I'm
recruiting net players don't ask the
parents you know they ask and then they
got to explain to their kids who went
played against but I got pictures in my
office with the recruits and the
pictures I have is a garden magic and
I'm garden Larry and I'm guarding I'm an
all-star game with with with Isaiah and
Jordan and Patrick Ewing those guys in
the background some of my photos are
pretty cool so they look at that and
they obviously know who those guys are
so I just talk about it and tell them
how I went to a mid-major and you know
back in 88 obviously it doesn't have the
same you know Internet and all that kind
of stuff and they still knew who I were
who I was and I got drafted in the 14th
pick in the first round so there's
mid-majors the way to go majorly Dan
majorly Grand Canyon University hey good
luck in the WAC tournament and it's been
a great success story it's always great
to talk to you thank you thank you
that's a
Dan Majerle Grand Canyon University for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]